[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
this guy got rocked the other smacked
his head against the wall
and then he popped you know again people
have to pop up people rushed the dude
and you know everyone dorian [ __ ]
came jumped in on it did anyone get a
sock on it didn't even punch that i said
i figured some people well people were
holding him we got him give him a little
butt
a little bit i'd like to kill you yeah
you're a little [ __ ] i mean i
definitely i know 100 i would if i had
the that opportunity i would punch that
guy just
that's because i would i would just be
like i don't ever get to punch someone
as hard as i can in the ribs i need to
do this right i would absolutely punch
him at least three times as hard as i
can yeah just like i have no emotional
investment in the person or whatever but
if i was in that situation
i went through a phase where i was doing
that in college to anybody that was
taking a uh
what the [ __ ] was a keg stand
anybody that was getting keg stand i
would get under punch with a stomach
this one dude i remember i was a pit i
was at my friend's fret and they were
doing a keg stand and the dude doing it
and i just socked him in the dick like
three times
his legs but people were holding him he
was trying to like curl up so dude
it's so funny
yeah next time you see someone doing a
keg stand definitely punch for the balls
oh [ __ ] punch from the belly oh punching
the belly in the balls
on a keg stance because they try to curl
up but people are like
holding their legs as hard as they can
they're getting restrained it's also too
it's funny because you're just light for
the party oh you're like oh it's my time
let's go
oh
oh oh my nuts someone's punching me in
the dick
that come of my legs yeah what's the
record 35 seconds watch this
oh [ __ ]
we should go to we should go to a uh a
college party
please and just punch somebody in the
dick any college listeners let us come
to your party let us come to your party
and
i don't think you can i like beer with
wings
hot wings yeah maybe fried chicken beer
goes nice i'll tell you what's a great
pairing of alcohol and food oysters and
martinis really oh yeah yeah damn dude i
did that on a date recently and it was
[ __ ] righteous oh it's his name
i'm still here baby
i'm just laying in the cut you guys go
ahead
you gave a girl a karate chop on the
butthole not as hard as you could
obviously because you'd split it in half
yeah but if you did like uh if you did
like a quick [ __ ]
to the butthole they'd
probably do something i mean yeah if you
can split them they'd probably split i
could just put a brick
i have no doubt i can see crosstalk's
butthole would be nothing girl's
butthole just
yeah dude give me you'd stack three of
them on top of each other
and they'd all just comment
it's probably all girls really wanted to
be cut in half from the butthole
um ma'am
i hit my girl with a funny one this
morning would you get it you would have
liked it she came in the room it was she
was looking for her laptop
and it was in the bed and i was like
what do you want she goes my laptop i go
when do you want it because now
[Music]
i go what do you want because my laptop
when do you want it because now
it's a fun little trick you can get very
good you see somebody looking for
something hit them with what do you want
when do you want it and then they go now
then you start a chat you go what do you
want
you drink wine when you're out on dates
sometimes
yeah what's his name
[Laughter]
you're getting roasted dude
jojo roasted
i brought that joke up
you didn't bring it up i brought it up i
wanted to taste it
he turned the [ __ ] gun around dude
turn it off [ __ ] grab the gun and
it's funny man i'm laughing still
thursday in san francisco
i was at cobbs
joe avery i think his last name is avery
i'm i hope i'm not [ __ ] that up he's
a great comedian
he
he had the attendees yeah in the green
room he had the chicken attendees on
thursday here's the test bed and he said
jeez these things are [ __ ] my stomach
up and threw them out
that's what i did wait he didn't even
finish attention he didn't even finish
his attendees he was like these are
these something's wrong
i'm not putting this on the club
but the next night i was like that might
have been a bad batch either way i'm
getting tandies for sure
so how much you've been looking forward
to how long have you been looking as
soon as he told me they made him sick i
was like
good it must be good that's a good bet
because joe's relative he looks like a
normal healthy guy yeah yeah i was like
he probably can't handle it for sure he
can't handle the heat of the truth he
has the tolerance he doesn't he didn't
build up the natural he doesn't eat
attendees every week yeah
so i ordered eod all attendees i ordered
them and i'm going to blame the tandy's
but
just because i'm trying to pretend it's
not alcohol
on friday
friday i got them saturday morning i
woke up dude my stomach was [ __ ] up
it hurts so bad
it is funny yeah the thing about that
and now that i think about it everyone
know who drinks a ton is always like i
had a bad hot dog at the snoko it's like
no you you blacked out at the snoke
yeah
there's always one food away it's like
oh man it must have been the chicken
fingers it's like dude that's you eat
chicken fingers every week must be that
batch of chicken fingers i barely
remember eating
it's not sitting well with me right now
without the alcohol consumption
so far today my stomach's good yeah
which is
that's nice you're in the clear i'm in
the clear right now but
what's what's on the menu for today
what's on the menu um i don't know last
night was just yogurt nice
soft dude
i'm [ __ ]
just imagine eating an activity it's so
funny right there eating an activity and
then putting it down and being like
you also got it you're gonna start you
might have to switch to cnn dude
fox news are getting too fired bro i'm
not being a jerk i'm saying you gotta
just take it easy for a couple days if
they just watch wolf blitzer because i
have tummy problems i'm a cnn guy no
you're telling me i got a monkey box now
my dad knows boys are skis are they yeah
absolutely they go to the men's club
they go to the elks get [ __ ] bombed
yep yo went to bingo i went to bingo at
the elks this weekend
sat down one on my first card what yeah
it's a bingo
yeah the geezers were none too pleased i
was flashy what
yeah people dude i've never i go there
sometimes bingo at the elks rules yeah
if you win everyone hates you i bet as
soon as you win people like oh
that's so funny
but how much did you win i want a
hundred bucks whoa
gave it to the squadron i was like put
it on pay for the pilsners for the table
bro that's what's respectable
that that uh that's you spiked the ball
in the end zone oh yeah and that's got
the money made sure everybody saw it
he probably hated that even more dude
phil phil hates to see me win really and
well i understand i'm a [ __ ] i'm
like look i you know it skips a
generation i have the championship gene
[Laughter]
okay
well it happens i don't know why it
skips a generation
[Laughter]
somebody saw you stun on the 100 yeah
yeah so was it 100 every time someone
won yeah and then the final that's 10.
uh
10 or 20 and you get a stack of 10 cards
and then there's 10 games and then
there's the blackout
you know what blackout is that's where
you got to get every single one
and that's the big money that was 500.
what it was great because i was like i
was one away i was like dude please let
me get this and then the lady behind me
was like bingo and i was like [ __ ] and
then i turned around it was like a lady
with her two children and she like
kissed her kid it was like
i was like oh [ __ ] glad she won i would
have felt like a dick i would have
wanted to be like oh it's a bingo
some ladies like relying on it for
groceries you know what i never played
mario 64. it's like the best one yeah i
hear but that's one of the only ones i
never played i have the new one or the
newest one which you guys have the
newest
mario kart mario kart 8 it's from like
it's it's a few years old at this point
yeah and then i have the game boy
advanced mario kart which is really good
gba
i have several gba's what
three crazy
where do you play them i have
40 plus systems in my house you do look
like an adult pokemon trainer
really
you look like a little pokemon dude
snorlax if you will you game hard yeah a
little fat pikachu
took almost everything in me to not open
the [ __ ] trash bag and eat all that
dude what was their excuse i don't know
i've seen plenty of black man eat half a
meatball sandwich and take that thing
back home yeah yeah save it for later
respect i say that respectfully i've
seen that happen many times you wear
construction yeah black guys typically
have half a hoagie on them
at any given moment
i've seen so many dudes when i was in
the labor union i'd work for my dad they
would like
eat half a meatball sandwich and just
chuck it in their pocket and they're
like oh my wife's gonna love this
sandwich dude
they'd have like a [ __ ] hot meatball
in a [ __ ] half a hoagie all day long
just in the back just [ __ ] wrapped up
and just be like chiseling concrete like
damn my wife's gonna love this
and that's happened enough for me to i
can say that with respect yeah that's
you know and once you pick up on that
you'll notice it like you'll see if you
pick up because a lot of people you
don't realize it but if you're just
walking down the street you'll see a
black guy drop a sandwich
almost every day
they come out like [ __ ] i'm gonna have
to pick up a
wrapped up subway sub they stay with one
half hockey on them at all times where
do they store it
yeah in a plastic
pockets yeah
yeah dude
that's why they always wear baggy
clothes
to accommodate their hoagies
[Laughter]
so
yeah they stay strapped with that witch
dude they got that witch at all times
dude
it's dangerous so that would have been
respectful you guys could have [ __ ]
pocketed your sandwich that's why
they're always so ornery
ornery
because they know that they have fragile
stuff on their persons so if you're like
bump into the maximum yeah
yeah if you step on their shoes like you
almost crushed my sub that's why they
keep randomly knocking out people in new
york
you get too close to the sandwich i
watch the asian lady get
popped on the face today dude you get
you get a hit you see one of them get
hit they can pick up their bros are you
bleeding through it's just a marinara
sauce
they're coming through
do you have to cut yellow paper ribs
yeah dude they get hit by a car you
gotta cut the jeans off
that's an italian
i got italian subs
save their lives think of a guy in an er
and some nurse like he's unconscious
she's like cutting it and she's cutting
into
so the cops are always pulling them over
just trying to oh i'm trying to come in
here i knew i was gonna get off stuff
yeah yeah they want a free sub they're
gonna call us let me pat you down
they're [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah they love it dude yeah oh dude
you're 100 take this back to the station
test it
they take the hogan they're like
it's legit
that's the battle between who loves
hoagies
[Laughter]
oh my god
jesus christ
um so saturday night
i got
blood tests done
and well it was funny because he the
the nurse came in and was asking me
questions
and then went and got a doctor and the
doctor came in immediately and was like
how much you drinking
he knew exactly what it was he knew
exactly i didn't even include the
attendees in the [ __ ] report i was
like
i was like how many days i was like uh
four four days a week he yeah like what
do you have like three
they always say that [ __ ] yeah but
you have like three drinks like no dude
yeah dude no one has three [ __ ]
drinks four days a week
if you're drinking four days a week
you're not drinking three drinks they
tell you on every commercial please
enjoy responding unless you're like a
mom dude coors light or
bud light would be furious to know that
you're not enjoying the products
responsibly like they're asking yeah i
know actually yeah people like how come
he's not sponsored it's because i drink
20 beers every time i'm on camera
they can't they can't be like nice
they literally can't be like this is
good i saw a homeless lady reading the
other day it made me laugh really she
was she was reading she was sitting
there like covered like blankets set up
everywhere she was reading 48 laws yeah
she was reading the art of not giving a
[ __ ]
no i didn't get to see what she was
reading but it was it made me laugh i
was like pretty funny why don't you get
to work talked up with a book stop
reading yeah
so it's funny to finish a long homeless
day and be like i'm going to settle in
with a nice book
i was thinking because we were
me and
the fellows were working on that king
show
we're trying to we're working on we're
right whatever but i was i was talking
to john yesterday it'd be funny if any
time we introduce a character you know
how like
in any series you add characters and
they leave they come and go yeah every
character that leaves the show needs to
kill themselves
there's never another way that somebody
leaves the show
every character eventually kills
themselves
just building up the circumstances to
why they have to do it would be so funny
yeah because yeah if the viewer knew
that they were going to eventually you
just slowly see like them drop a cup and
be like
like just the whole time small things
bothering them immensely especially the
medieval suicide methods would be so
nothing but self guillotines oh dude
even though yeah
entering the iron what's like the thing
they put on
iron maiden
[Laughter]
they're bad boys the boys were up to no
good they were bad boys i wonder how
tolerant they were of other people
though in terms of like people's beliefs
and i'm sure they were very lifestyles
now they put them in a [ __ ] nail bed
i closed it
the doctor comes in he's like how many
are you drinking i was like about i
don't know like 10.
10 is like so you're having 40 drinks a
week
it's like
yeah if you're gonna be a dick about it
well they come in there you get big well
sometimes they come in bigger cans so
more like 35
30. true
sometimes it's a i pitcher i use phil
math i'm like i had two drinks yeah
it's a picture
[ __ ]
uh he was nice though he he was
courteous he was like
i don't mean this
he was like trying to like he was like
trigger warning yeah yeah i don't want
to shame you you are drinking
excessively
he's like i'm not judging you for that
but the yeah just by the sheer liquid
volume i'd say it's a lot
so then but it was funny too i was
hitting with the [ __ ] but yeah it's like
it's just light beers it's not
no that's still
i was like it's not like i'm chugging
liquor you know
he was like
no i have no idea what you're talking
about dude you could if you want to
especially because if we went to a
college party the only way we'd get
invited is if one dude liked our podcast
yeah they'd bring us in and be like yo
these are uh
my favorite podcasters and everyone
would be like who the [ __ ] are these
losers and then we'd punch them and then
punch a kid in the dick and everyone
would be like oh
you're the best get that kid out of here
i'm gonna show up for the college party
dress like it's uh can't hardly wait
i'll have like ski goggles on my side of
my head or we're both gonna get pants
that's my the ultimate fear with college
students is getting pants
yeah dude i uh
we should do that
[Music]
you